I remember I was dropped by my agency
and I learned how horrible this business
can be when you don't mean anything I
Disappeared for seven seven years a
little like seven years three months
three and a half months no that's a long
time to be away from the business people
go away and stuff and I showed showed up
on a brand new show called American Idol
and it was like you were it was like
yesterday they saw you here we are oh
yeah Paul it became well no it was it
was touted it's going to be the most
Velveeta Cheesy show that's gonna ruin
the music in this watching that show I
couldn't stop watching it for years we
became like the Death Star like to every
other network if a Network dropped 50 in
all their ratings we still were like 100